[Music]
i want to start off by congratulating
you uh you go to the emmys a couple days
ago and you win two i know two more
emmys in one night
that's crazy yeah it was crazy i mean
it's nice it's deserved but uh that's
fantastic to walk around with two of
those things and you you have a few
already do you not i do have a few
others that i got from the that
wonderful west wing show right and
and um they are in my uh in my house
above my television set where i i felt
was appropriate for them to to
rest and be there right except for when
i have friends over who are very
creative they like to fancy themselves
interior decorators and they decide they
should not be above the television but
they should be
somewhere else every once in a while you
had friends come that were visiting come
into your house to celebrate with me i
came in i went to the grocery store to
get some things and came in and they
were gone i was like did was i robbed
what happened to miami's right and then
i and this is we have the picture of
what your friends did to your emmys
there they are in the pool
i love that the girls were it went out
for some air that's very nice
that turtle did not live past that photo
shoot no the emmys of things are sharp
the emmy is the sharpest and most deadly
of all the awards
it has
it's i mean it's a it's a weapon yeah it
is a weapon and uh so i'm surprised i'm
surprised that it did not make it past
yeah you have six of them though is it
right six yeah so if someone if there
was a burgle you could just start
chucking them adam
be a fun way for guy to go i do under my
bed i keep a baseball bat and an emmy
just in case
that's good see the oscar is useless as
a weapon that's why i don't aspire to
one uh
golden globes got some half though you
could hurt somebody with a golden globe
the sag award that's the one that's oh
is that bad which is oh it's like a face
it's like an actor face the whole
actor's it's a whole body and you know
every it's a beautiful body of a man
it's the beautiful butt so you you've
admired you've admired the body
i have admired the body of the sag award
he's got a great ass he's got a great
yeah the oscar is sort of like got
the oscar has no genitals it has no it's
not a real guy yeah it's uh it's just
not it's not cool
um i don't know why we got on this whole
but if you're gonna get killed with
something i'd rather get killed with an
oscar i would too yeah yeah yeah this is
the dumbest conversation
but i mean
i love it still the same and i'll get a
transcript later and figure out what
happened
where did we go now you know i did run
into uh anna ferris and uh she came over
here and she's your co-star on mom and
she was she was over here and
we were talking and she was talking
about sort of selling you out saying you
like to uh you pretty much enjoy uh
kissing women on the lips when you greet
them oh now
hold on now isn't that fair
nothing's wrong with that i just like to
be there
anna and i did
share a kiss and that was after we had
to do so much press for the start of mom
and and i said let's just be silly let's
just do it you know us making out i
thought it was funny and now it's sort
of become my thing because i did it with
um
uh at one of the pre-emmy parties i ran
into cloris leachman i'm such a huge fan
of hers and i'd never met her before and
i was i couldn't think of anything to
say so i just went in to kiss her and
then
she started we had we had kind of a huge
makeout session uh at this party
and i think
[Applause]
i'm not going to do that with men who
are
married or uh or
women who are gay i will only make out
with women who are straight and men who
are gay
i mean that's less threatening i'm not
going to threaten anybody i may be gay
it's it's a day-to-day kind of thing
a constant struggle
i like that you you have it very it's
very clear in your mind what the rules
are i don't know what's appropriate but
i do like to and then and then i'm sorry
i'm going over but ed asner is guest
starring on mom yeah and he he's one of
i mean oh my god he's a hero and another
one i met him and i had no idea what to
say to him
and uh he took my i took my hand and he
literally he licked my all the way up my
arm with his tongue he does that and i
was like it's he licked he started down
here and went all the way up and licked
up my i like how if you're a certain
kind of celebrity you can get away with
anything
i've done that to women on the bus and
i'm a creep suddenly
i'm a perv
right
but he does it and he's cool he's so
cool i call it the lizard when i do it
we'll talk later